[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour on est en direct aujourd'hui
pour vous faire vivre le lancement de
cette fusée que vous voyez sur cette
image Starship la fusée SpaceX
Cyril van Elberg bonjour Cyril Vincent
cette fusée qui va décoller c'est un
grand événement il semblerait dans la
science oui oui c'est vraiment une
première c'est le premier vol d'essai de
la fusée Starship dans son ensemble
le vaisseau qu'on voit à l'État au
deuxième étage donc la partie un peu
plus sombre alors on la voit moins bien
là oui il y a une partie avec un
vaisseau il est un peu futuriste ça ça a
déjà volé ça déjà été question 2021 ça
fait un vol jusqu'à 10 km d'altitude ça
c'est le revenu se poser la verticale et
là on teste l'ensemble de la fusée avec
la première étage c'est gigantesque ça
donne on n'a pas d'idée de l'échelle en
fait ça fait 120 mètres de haut
un immeuble de 30 étages 40 étages
c'est plus grand que la fusée lunaire
qui avait emmené les astronautes
américains sur la lune dans l'émission
Apollo c'est beaucoup plus grand là on a
parlé d'Ariane 5 vendredi on était
ensemble ou pas
non plus à jouer à côté mais quand même
rien de 5 c'est 55 m de hauteur 60
mètres configuration et c'est 550 tonnes
au décollage
là on est on est 10 fois plus gros en
fait on est presque 5000 tonnes au
décollage à pleine charge donc c'est
c'est un monstre c'est vraiment un
monstre les capacités d'emports sont
aussi gigantesques
Elon Musk parle d'envoyer 100 personnes
dans l'espace en même temps dans le
vaisseau donc la partie supérieure
une partie qui est enfumée on va dire ça
c'est ça c'est le premier étage ça c'est
le booster c'est ça qui va accélérer la
fusée au décollage c'est 9 mètres de
diamètre 70 m de haut c'est déjà que
c'est quelque chose de monstrueux ça il
y a 33 moteurs en bas
des moteurs qui sont chacun est plus
gros plus puissant que le surim5 il y a
un moteur
Vulcain et deux boosters à poudre mais
il y a un moteur et chacun des 33
moteurs et plus puissant que le moteur
le seul moteur n'a rien de 5 donc on est
super natifs
on va essayer de rester calme mais le
c'est quand même assez incroyable ça va
être voilà si tout se déroule qu'on a eu
on a entendu une info qui avait un
problème de pressurisation sur le on est
en face de remplissage oui parce que
alors ça on a parlé un peu enfin parce
que on me disait que c'est un lancement
on va dire à risque dans le sens où on
n'est pas sur un lancement vendredi on
se disait ça va partir a priori sauf
problème c'est fiable on est tranquille
voilà plus tu te sens lancement là il y
a pas eu vraiment de test grandeur
nature avant à l'ensemble du lanceur a
jamais été testé donc il y avait déjà
une mise à feu des moteurs des 33
moteurs du premier étage
mais la fusée était restée au pas de tir
donc les moteurs étaient à 1800
voilà là les images qu'on a en fait
c'est on a vu des images du de starbase
starbase c'est le site de lancement et
d'assemblage des fusées qui a été
construit par SpaceX en moins en
quelques années
dans un petit village du Texas qui
s'appelle bocat Chika qui est en bord de
mer et dans lequel c'était vraiment il y
avait rien de l'activité le week-end
c'était d'aller avec son pick-up faire
des barbecues sur la plage d'accord et
là ils ont changé ça en Silicone Valley
de l'espace c'est le oui c'est le plus
gros pas de tir maintenant enfin on
connaissait Cap Canaveral en Floride et
là maintenant Boca Chica au Texas va
devenir avec Starship
le site numéro 1 sur lequel tous les
regards se concentre aujourd'hui
effectivement vous voyez vous voyez ces
images alors on le disait il faut il
faut maintenant voir ça à l'école parce
qu'il y a quand même des risques
donc tout peut se passer
SpaceX le 1 6 là dessus circule le
succès n'est absolument pas garanti bon
et donc chaque chose qui se déroulera
bien dans le dans le plan de vol sera un
succès pour pour SpaceX l'idée c'est
pour les ingénieurs d'accumuler de la
connaissance comprendre ce qui se passe
en espérant que ça se passe bien et
évidemment mais même en cas d'échec en
fait ils apprendront des choses et ça
fait partie de la démarche expérimentale
de spécif depuis le début il y a
beaucoup d'échecs ils produisent
énormément de prototype on a vu tout à
l'heure sur les images il y avait trois
Starship alignés les uns que les autres
c'est les appareils qui ont déjà volé
qui ont fait des vols d'essai utilisable
du coup qui sont réutilisables certains
Starship ont déjà été détruits ils sont
ils ont essayé de déposer les verticales
ils ont explosé au sol oui et ça c'est
ça on joue beaucoup dans sa
communication là encore au début de live
stream de de SpaceX on a vu tout ça qui
qui on a vu pas mal d'atterrissage ratés
on vous rappelle quand même la prouesse
que ça représente vous arrivez à faire
des lieux fusées pour la faire se
reposer après bien sûr
et donc et donc on est on est sur un vol
qui est
en fait chaque seconde de plus qui se
déroulera pendant après le lancement
après le décollage sera gagné pour
SpaceX il faut comprendre
de toute façon la fusée va être perdue
oui parce qu'en fait elle est prévue
pour être récupérable prévue pour
récupérer l'ensemble la fusée c'est une
des premières de cette conception
incroyable c'est il va à la fois
récupérer le premier étage c'est ce que
SpaceX fait déjà avec Falcon 9 Falcon 9
c'est la concurrente d'Ariane 5
et et on veut aussi récupérer le
vaisseau donc Starship qui était le
deuxième étage et ça c'est jamais ça
c'est jamais fait une personne n'a
jamais réussi donc pour ce vol d'essai
il y aura pas de récupération mais ils
vont simuler va ils vont simuler comme
si on pouvait récupérer plus tard alors
pour le premier étage ils vont simuler
un atterrissage mais au-dessus de l'eau
au-dessus de donc des de la merde de
Gold du Mexique il y aura pas de barge
il y a pas qui vont ils vont essayer de
faire descendre à la verticale le
laitage je suis désolé je fais plein de
gestes avec les mains mais on le voit on
le voit on vous voit non on vous voit de
toute façon on imagine donc les les 70
mètres du premier étage qui descendent
la verticale et qui a les Moloto le
moteur s'allument à quelques centaines
de mètres d'altitude se ralentissent et
un peu du surplace au dessus des vagues
donc ça sera une simulation de
d'amerrissage et on coupe les moteurs et
l'ensemble tombe dans la mer donc il
sera perdu pour le pour le deuxième
étage pour Starship
il y aura pas de tentative de
d'atterrissage à la verticale
donc on sera vraiment sur une une
descente balistique une chute libre
après une phrase qui sera une phrase qui
sera critique c'est la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère parce que ce vaisseau il va
aller dans l'espace il va pas faire une
orbite totale autour de la Terre mais il
va en faire trois quarts donc il va
aller on part du Texas il faut imaginer
on part du Texas on va vers l'Est on
traverse le Golf du Mexique
il va sur brûler l'Atlantique si vous
voulez l'Afrique si vous voulez un grand
bout de pacifique et le Starship il va
tomber en mer
dans le Pacifique ou l'arche de la
Californie donc je vais faire un tour du
globe en peu plus d'une heure
il y aura pas de récupération donc tout
sera perdu donc cette ça fait partie de
la stratégie SpaceX on l'a dit tout à
l'heure enfin le on est dans une
démarche expérimentale on teste les
choses on sait que ça peut péter ça peut
exploser et parfois aussi ça se passe
bien heureusement mais si tout se passe
bien si ça marche bien l'idée de cette
fusée c'est que je crois dans deux ans
on part sur une avec alors ça c'est le
calendrier de la NASA 2025 ce vaisseau
noir qu'on voit là c'est Starship il y
aura une version sans elle
conçue pour la NASA pour poser les
astronautes américains sur la surface de
la Lune
pas dans Starship ils vont décoller dans
la fusée de la NASA qui s'appelle les
céleste dans lequel il y a une capsule
une capsule Orion qui est un peu plus
classique dans la conception beaucoup
plus classique
c'est une parachute une capsule qui
redescend sur terre sous parachute et
donc cette capsule elle va aller autour
de la Lune et autour de la Lune elle va
avoir un rendez-vous avec Starship et là
rendez-vous transfert de l'équipage de
la capsule vers Starship et ses Starship
qui va se poser sur la Lune qui dépose
les astronautes qui vont faire leurs
activités ils redécolent rendez-vous
avec la capsule et c'est la capsule qui
revient sur Terre donc c'est une partie
critique du plan de la NASA pour
retourner sur la Lune on voit les 33
moteurs
chacun fait 200 tonnes de poussée donc
chaque moteur peut faire décoller 200
tonnes d'accord donc on va faire
calculer
il y en a 33 donc il y a eu donc un
essai de mise à feu
31 sont bien allumés un n'a pas été
allumé pour des problèmes techniques et
un autre c'est un au bout de quelques
secondes pour des problèmes donc il y
ait eu 31 sur 33 qui ont bien fonctionné
mais ça suffit pour SpaceX il considère
que c'est un succès et d'ailleurs pour
réussir à faire
soulever enfin pour réussir à faire
pousser de ce que j'ai compris ils ont
SpaceX a mis en place ils ont surélever
la fusée pour la faire décoller on voit
en fait la fusée elle est posée sur un
support métallique c'est presque un
trépied
en acier il est caché par le compte à
rebours là sur l'image de SpaceX
mais ça c'est une astuce café spécifique
pour éviter de creuser
un Carnot c'est des grands canaux qui
dévient les flammes on le voit ça sur le
lancement de la navette on voyait ça sur
le lancement dans son Ariane 5 c'était
Soyouz chez les Russes qui avait inventé
ça et ça c'est un moyen d'éviter ce que
les gaz d'échappement et les flammes
reviennent sur la fusée pour la et la
BIM au décollage et donc là l'astuce
l'astuce de SpaceX c'est le surélever
d'une vingtaine de mètres
la fusée mettre des déflecteurs et on
imagine aussi qu'ils ont une dalle
d'acier une dalle de béton assez costaud
pour supporter la poussée des on a quand
même 6400 tonnes de pousser avec les 33
moteurs donc c'est c'est assez colossal
décollage prévu dans 5 minutes et 49
secondes si le décollage se passe bien
évidemment parce qu'on vous le disait
c'est pas sûr du tout que le que le
décollage se passe bien alors l'objectif
premier c'est la lune et là on est en
face de remplissage donc on voit le on
voit les fumées qui sont selon le du
lanceur c'est c'est le carburant et et
l'oxygène liquide qui sont en train
d'être chargés
carburant c'est du méthane donc du gaz
naturel mais qui est liquifié qui est
très très froid et l'oxygène liquide
donc c'est le même carburant pour les
deux étages
et donc ça crée cette et donc ça crée
c'est condensation c'est fumer
condensation on voit les grands avoir
qui sont à gauche on va à gauche c'est
les grands avoir dans lequel les gaz
sont stockés d'accord ils sont transmis
vers là-bas et d'ailleurs on voit
d'ailleurs cette toute cette fumée sur
le pas de tir aussi il y a beaucoup de
bruit avant le décollage et en fait
là si on se demande mais alors quel est
le critère de réussite ou d'échec du vol
pour moi l'échec aujourd'hui c'est si la
fusée explose proche du pas de tir et
détruite
tout le reste ce sera un succès pour ce
musique mais si il y a un échec
catastrophique et que le parce que
quelqu'un
dans la fusée donc si ça expose c'est
une bombe monstrueuse enfin c'est oui il
faut réussir à le faire décoller
effectivement parce que une fois qu'il y
a la décollé et qu'elle est partie du
pas de tir quoi qu'il arrive après ce
sera quand même une réussite oui en fait
une fois que la fusée d'école les
ingénieurs de SpaceX ils engrangent les
données ils apprennent des choses sur
leur lanceur il a jamais vol il a jamais
volé donc tout ce qui est structurel et
des formations en vol
c'est c'est
en fait ils vont apprendre des choses
enfin donc la première étape qui vont
surveiller c'est la séparation entre les
deux étages ça c'est au bout d'une
minute et 55 secondes je crois et donc
c'est toutes ces phases là c'est les
moments où les ingénieurs vont accumuler
des données
[Musique]
ça permet de hauteur au dessus de la
plage
est-ce que c'est un échec de ne pas
lancer
ça en fait on disait voilà mais
à partir du moment où ça vole et ça
décolle ils apprennent quelque chose et
en fait en fait il y a une procédure qui
commence 2h avant le lancement et toute
cette procédure remplissage mise en
place des systèmes de vol c'est
apprendre quelque chose ça prend aussi
quelque chose en compte non non il sait
pas c'est pour un vol d'essai de pas
partir le premier jour c'est tout à fait
normal c'est exactement ce qui s'était
passé pour le premier vol de la fusée
lunaire de la NASA et ça laisse
personne n'avait été surpris enfin
les spécialistes que j'interrogeais me
dit me disaient mais on serait plutôt
surpris si ça vole du le premier jour
quoi enfin le la séquence d'ensemble de
paramètres qu'il faut mettre dans le bon
ordre et et tout fonctionne bien pour
que ça décolle
voilà et là donc c'est un tweet d'Elon
masque publié à 3h11 donc il y a un peu
moins de 5 minutes
c'est c'est un une
valve de pressurisation donc en fait les
les réservoirs sont pressurisés avec du
gaz du gazinière de cette fois que c'est
le l'azote c'est ça qui leur donne leur
structurer leur forme
donc c'est un problème
de remplissage séminaire voilà c'est
pour c'est pas mineur parce que ça
empêche le vol non non mais c'est une
une valse en des centaines donc je
ils vont essayer de comprendre et il dit
qu'elle est gelée cette image donc
ça peut être que ça peut être dû à quoi
ben ça peut être un flux carburant trop
élevé par rapport donc avec un effet de
refroidissement plus prévu que ce qu'ils
avaient envisagé enfin je n'en sais rien
moi je oui alors vous vous demandez de
vous demander de savoir ce qui se passe
en ce moment au Texas sachant qu'a
priori la seule personne qui le sache
vraiment ça a l'air d'être Elon Musk
puisque c'est lui qui a qui qui a
annoncé ça effectivement donc pas de
lancement aujourd'hui peut-être en ce
moment avec cette fusée qui comme on dit
le but c'est pas forcément en fait c'est
mars c'est plus long en fait en fait
quand Elon Musk a présenté en
grand public en 2010 2016 il y avait une
première version qui était assez
différente en 2017 une version qui
ressemble à déjà pas mal à ça
son but c'est de il dit c'est le moyen
d'avoir une civilisation
interplanétaire
c'est un objectif qui est pour le très
sérieux et la Lune c'est le contrat de
la NASA donc c'est un milliard plus d'un
milliard et demi de dollars pour les
dire à développer cette fusée mais pour
lui il voit plus loin il voit plus loin
que la Lune c'est vraiment mars
[Musique]
et pourquoi pas aussi explorer d'autres
corps du système solaire enfin des
astéroïdes et en fait avec l'engin qu'il
est en train de concevoir
ça ouvre ça ouvre tout
on peut faire des lancements hyper
lourds on n'a pas parlé des performances
mais donc envoyer 150 tonnes en orbite
d'un seul coup d'un seul lancement
c'est l'équivalent de silencement
d'Ariane 5 aujourd'hui donc c'est à dire
que c'est avec trois lancements de
Starship on peut envoyer une
constellation de 2000 satellites
d'ailleurs c'est un papier que je vous
invite à retrouver sur le site du Figaro
de Véronique Guimard ça peut tout
changer en termes de d'industrie de de
satellite alors qu'on l'a vu le
chronomètre et bien c'est arrêté à 20
secondes du coup et je crois que c'est
la fin de la transmission du j'imagine
puisqu'ils ils vont pas rester avec nous
pendant pendant plusieurs rendez-vous
demain on peut se donner rendez-vous
demain si il part demain parce que des
dates de reprises sont possibles dans la
semaine selon La Dépêche qu'on vient de
recevoir donc effectivement il est
possible que Starship partent plutôt
dans la semaine on le verra on le suivra
bien évidemment une petite Figaro c'est
toujours des événements
incroyables à suivre
bon donc on a un peu déçu mais
voilà c'est que partir mise
la fusée est toujours sympathie elle est
voilà il est en bon état il y a pas de
raison et il vaut mieux il vaut mieux
pas lancer ce que vous dites il vaut
mieux pas lancer et des risquer de tout
détruire que d'attendre et on n'aura pas
une fois que un projet comme ça
qui est très longtemps à assembler il
vaut mieux perdre ou deux jours oui
toujours toujours en fait la prudence
c'est
presque une évidence mais c'est il y a
pas d'autres objectifs que de tester la
fusée qui est pas de rendez-vous qui
vous paraît il y a pas de contraintes de
temps
un petit peu parlé donc personne en fait
personne ne croit de manière crédit
sérieuse que que Starship serait
totalement prêt en 2025
personne ne sait et mais en fait quand
on se suicide c'est Elon Musk lance des
programmes ils sont toujours un petit
peu en retard mais les objectifs en
général ils sont atteints
plus tard donc voilà ce lancement qui
n'aura pas lieu aujourd'hui mais qui
pourrait avoir lieu plus tard dans la
semaine j'ai bien une dépêche qu'on
vient de recevoir les équipes de SpaceX
continuer à faire tourner le compte à
rebours on l'a vu pour simuler toutes
les opérations du décollage sous forme
d'une répétition générale ça a été
stoppé juste avant le moment prévu du
lancement des dates de reprise sont plus
dans la semaine ça veut dire que ça peut
alors on va attendre on ne sait pas
encore mais ça peut partir demain après
demain selon aussi s'il fait beau parce
que il y a aussi un petit problème météo
est importante c'est sur si il y a des
orages et ou des vents à haute altitude
ça colle
merci beaucoup Cyril d'avoir été avec
nous peut-être que on va se retrouver
dans la semaine du coup si j'espère on
espère effectivement pour revoir un vrai
décollage de de SpaceX pour voir ce
Starship décoller merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup et
voilà on vous donne rendez-vous bientôt
sur le Figaro alors on vous donne
rendez-vous déjà à 16h pour la question
du jour à 17h pour point de vue vos
rendez-vous habituels 18h le buzz TV à
20h et d'ailleurs dès 19h45 vous pourrez
suivre l'allocution d'Emmanuel Macron
sur le site du Figaro et à 21h le Club
International bonne soirée sur Figaro
live